so I don't that's the only thing that he
looks at here what maybe there's
something else in there somewhere oh
that's the wrong way oh stop lying at
bay yeah yeah no I don't know we need to
do something with this but it's not oh
maybe the extinguisher oh that's all I
wanted extinguisher yes maybe we can he
said there was like some kind of
poisoning thing in it right what am I
gonna find something it's on fire cat
balloon obviously is going to help what
oh my god oh my god but I i think that
the point of this is that they're gonna
break through my cat balloon hmm no no
no let's pick it up I can't can I pick
it up oh thank god okay we'll put down
this guy whoever that was poet right I
don't know who he is put that down and
then put bread in there and then they're
gonna come over and eat the bread oh my
god I can't believe I just figure that
out that would have taken me so long
it's gonna pop when they eat it that's
what's gonna happen oh my god are you
this game is so [ __ ] hot okay
let's see if that works yeah no didn't
you scared away those ones though Hey oh
my god holy [ __ ] yeah a little yeah you
lousy little ledge peckers I didn't
understand an American I didn't sound
like many at all you must come with me
young ones for I am the Grim Reaper the
Grim Reaper all right that is the
biggest triumph of my that would have
taken me I was just like the [ __ ]
worms thing man oh this game like how
hectic the music is when you're on the
roof to it's really intense man let me
come back down here and give this guy
and dugas yes it's my testicles yeah it
was my testicles all along all right
thank God I still have my cat balloon so
we give him to this guy so he can train
them as carrier pigeons what's that I
don't want to break no okay yeah all
right we're gonna give the testicles to
the nice man first check these babies
out I know ladies level entire army of
winged messengers our revolution can
spread now across the land we hurried on
the shimmering wings of justice thanks
to you it damn right it's thanks to my
agent calavera oh the lacework friend of
the revolution agent carrera and now now
let me be of service to you go to the
donor who Wakaba my friend you want to
find your lost soul oh how do you know
we've left I don't but everyone wants to
get to the ninth underworld must cross
the sea of lament and therefore must go
to RuvA kava to get passage on a ship of
course yes as you get there before she
does go find her but it may be quite a
way how how would I as long as it takes
know that I met before how it are you in
love with her love yes love is for the
living cell no I'm only after her for
one reason dad [ __ ] jeez my ticket out
of here uh yeah I suppose that makes
sense to
either way he's just using it on my
mom's I would love that lady to provide
forest cool all right how did he get out
here Gladys what's wrong what you die if
you leave the unlit the first place
wherever it was hi what are you doing
here I'm sorry nature let me do buddy
hey I can fly it as well the only thing
that makes me happy oh my god that
actually this happened did he just die
Oh No Oh what have you done oh no no
surely I can save him broad no surely
it's still beating it's okay it's still
beating hot oh god on spiders spiders of
wings nuts spite of bats ok it's just
sleeping it's fine throw it down this
way right uh spiders all right at every
game have spied uh uh uh let's get it
hello
it's stuck in there good site yeah we
can cut it out he always says the
[ __ ] about not being able to do this
but let's give it a try no he's finally
this is come in handy as it there oh is
that even god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god so that's not what I wanted
dad said to cut it in a different spot
maybe I don't think that's gonna work no
trap from this side I feel like that's
gonna work otherwise he would have just
said but that's not dead no whatever it
is that he says let's try it again
doesn't like this time and then I know
notes already what done that it's not
gonna work my scythe I like done that
[ __ ] let's listen miss up well then put
your plate away you dick
oh my god they got rid of my cat balloon
when I left that's the worst I guess I
could always use a spare let's chuck
this in in the tree in the thing huh
they don't seem very interested in that
bone I put in there mmm wonder what that
means it's just hard by let's just drop
this one I'm carrying around too many of
those old are you you already have one
look there's already a bone in it it's
already a bar now let's try and cite the
bone other why they wouldn't have had
the end of it I feel like it wouldn't
have had if it wasn't gonna help am I
right about that yeah oh my god of
course oh that's genius I would not have
guessed that was gonna happen Oh Thor
spiders no more demon hard to eat nice
esteem and ever and you mean spy to bats
I think you'll find mmm musics a bit
unsettling ah what is it no this is not
what I want no this way oh ok buddy your
heart's just here it's right [ __ ]
here take it back it's still beating huh
he's still beating heart diode me buddy
I love you what is yes yes it is I have
no idea why you ripped it out of your
own chest exactly strong beating good
heart okay Hulk so why did he go Hulk I
don't I assure you the missing woman
will be found I will personally track
her down myself just
you personally picked her up from the
land of Olivia that was my intention but
agent kalimera somehow got to her first
yeah when my sick ride tomorrow we gave
you all the best clients you had all the
advantages so how does get advantages
able to sneak in and eat your ah the
plot thickens can't get too mad at
domino that wasn't his fault oh I can
you should know i can get to mod 0
what's happening not until now this is
like a an actual plot twist oh my god
they killed him my weight is already
dead I shouldn't oh they sprouted him oh
oh my god some reason i was expecting
juleps huh well maybe mr. Keller better
oh my god why is this happening why
don't you personally go down to the
basement and his school team up yeah
about that they were going to spur out
Manny never want to go for a run I feel
like we should not do this I feel like
this is a bad idea and we should not
ever go back there because manny they
want to sprout you this is all still a
cutscene by the way oh no it's not now
whoa oh geez oh this is tough Oh
oh lordy this is hard to drive oh my god
I'm accidentally reversing even though
I'm not facing that way at all ah oh my
god what oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is
ridiculous no oh my god I cut this is
nope nope oh my god [ __ ] i'm trying to
do suckles right now is all I'm trying
to do that's not happening Oh God oh
[ __ ] so thank you to everyone who watch
this let's play this is where I'm going
to end it on pot aight i hope you all
enjoyed it very much i enjoyed making it
and i think this game is absolutely
fantastic so if you enjoyed watching you
should definitely go and buy it it's so
culturally rich whilst also being really
really woody and really really hard and
I'm kind of in love with it